البطاطا المقليه طبق الصغار والكبار الذي
لا يختلف عليه سكان الارض تقريبا قد يسبب
الاكتئاب نتائج دراسه جديده اجراها فريق
صيني على اكثر من 140 الف شخص جاء فيها ان
الاستهلاك المفرط للاطعمه المقليه وعلى
راسها البطاطا يزيد خطر الاصابه بالقلق
بنسبه 12% والاكتئاب بنسبه سبعه في المئه
يعتقد الفريق ان ماده الاكريلاميد
الكيميائيه التي تتشكل اثناء عمليه القلي
على درجات حراره عاليه قد تكون المسؤوله
عن ارتفاع نسب القلق والاكتئاب لكن
الباحثين يقولون ان نتائج اوليه واختلفوا
حول ما اذا كانت المقليات تؤثر سلبا على
الصحه العقليه ام ان الاشخاص الذين يعانون
في الاساس من الاكتئاب اتجهوا الى تناول
الاطعمه المقليه كاليه دفاعيه لتخفيف
الاعراض